[Musik]
jahr für jahr beginnen mehr als
hunderttausend menschen ein neues leben
in der schweiz
was bringt sie dazu ihre heimat zu
verlassen und in der schweiz neu zu
beginnen und werden sie in der schweiz
ihr glück finden
[Musik]
wir haben menschen aus vier ländern bei
ihrem neuanfang in der schweiz begleitet
viel
[Musik]
es ist so still hier ein paar autofahrer
keine menschen
was bisher geschah raul ist in der
schweiz angekommen
zunächst muss er sich ohne familie
durchschlagen neben der arbeit bereitet
raul die ankunft seiner frau und seiner
tochter vor dreieinhalb dann wäre sie in
dieser klasse
warum gibt es hier immer zwei
waschbecken im tessin verbringen rabanne
und rasant die ersten ferien ihres
lebens diese woche haben wir wirklich
tolle sachen gemacht auch abend bis
mitternacht
das war spannend bleibt auch einfach
hier
die familie möchte ihre älteste tochter
aus libyen in die schweiz holen doch ein
befreundeter anwalt nimmt ihr die
hoffnung leider ist es nicht mehr
möglich euer gesucht direkt bei einer
schweizer botschaft im ausland
einzureichen
juli und 4 sind frisch verheiratet jetzt
will er seinen job über bord werfen und
einen beruflichen neustart wagen
hast du unterschrieben ja nicht jeden
morgen dasselbe
anders als fabian fühlt sich sehr wohl
in ihrem job auch wenn sie täglich
mehrere stunden pendeln muss lisas
ferien in portugal sind von problemen
überschattet ihrer mutter geht es
schlechter als erwartet ihr älterer sohn
ist seit einem jahr arbeitslos war lange
klar kommen und einen job finden damit
es vorangeht
weißt du was ich sagen will selbst
[Musik]
lisa etwas ihren ferien in portugal
zurück in der schweiz
am ende des monats für die finanziell
regelmäßig eng für sie die hälfte ihres
einkommens von 4800 franken schickt ihn
nach hause zu ihrer familie
ich kann jetzt nur rechnen ab wenn ich
von portugal zurückgehen wie viel geld
ich da im moment zur verfügung habe ich
würde jetzt auch mal gerne ferien für
mich machen wo anders also nicht
unbedingt portugal weil portal ist immer
sachen erledigen leben nur wenn ich muss
und jetzt weihnachten bis jetzt das
spezieller fall weil ich bis weihnachten
und gut meine mutter 87 und sie zeigt
erinnert ihr zu sagen ich weiß ich hab
ich weihnachten mit ihr verbringen und
so lange sie lebt ist so eine sache
deshalb möchte ich irgendwie im frühjahr
bis sommer muss ich was für mich machen
also auf während für mich in gedanken
ist lisa die ganze zeit in portugal und
bei ihrer mutter und der 87 jährigen zu
helfen hatte ihr für 400 euro pro monat
eine haushaltshilfe organisiert
trotz ihrer probleme
lisa findet immer ein wenig lebensfreude
um sie an andere weiterzugeben wenn nur
die einsamkeit nicht wäre
[Musik]
nein die kenne ich nicht
auf der anderen seite ich komme aus
portugal
ich komme aus portugal spanien spanien
[Musik]
abräumen nein
hast du einen schatz
[Musik]
fast schon gehabt
ja
bis später
die ersehnte neue liebe in der schweiz
sie lässt auf sich warten
[Musik]
dieser teil kommt da rein und die platte
dann dahin für fabia öffnet sich ein
neues kapitel
er hat seinen job gekündigt und eine
kunstschmiede erworben
der vorbesitzer gibt ihm noch ein paar
gute ratschläge mit auf den weg
das ist mein kleines paradies 4
früher habe ich so was in meiner
freizeit gemacht das hobby
jetzt ist es mein beruf das wird
wunderbar mein traumjob erteilen
dennoch es ist der sprung ins kalte
wasser in die finanzielle unsicherheit
[Musik]
immerhin in sachen versicherung ist
alles bestens
das geht super schnell hier in der
schweiz die unterlagen kommen innerhalb
von ein paar tagen
und wenn ich das mal liegen lasse
erinnern
fabian taucht in seine neue welt ein
neben der kunstschmiede gehört auch ein
24 stunden notfall schlüssel service zu
seinem neuen unternehmen
und da hat er noch einiges zu lernen
gestern hatte ich drei einsätze am
anfang war der vorbesitzer mit dabei den
dritten satz habe ich dann alleine
gemacht
es ist glatt gelaufen da war schon
erleichtert die person die ich die tür
öffnen konnte war so dankbar
das war ein super gefühl für mich
ein
lehnen sie sich das hatten wir schon mal
gemacht und die anderen wörter beginnen
wir mal kommt aus ghana
wissen sie wo ghana ist in afrika
was verstehen wir nicht zwei jahre nach
ihrer ankunft in der schweiz beginnt abi
rasch italienisch zu lernen eine sprache
die ihre kinder bereits perfekt
beherrschten inkasso bietet sprachkurse
speziell für frauen mit 47 drückt abir
nun erneut die schulbank
vergessen sie nicht dass das männliche
und weibliche namen gibt männlich
weiblich karte
einige der frauen sind nie oder nur
wenige jahre zur schule gegangen
zum teil stammen sie aus ländern in
denen anders als in der schweiz
der zugang zur bildung oftmals vor allem
männern vorbehalten ist
im kurs lernen sie nicht nur die neue
sprache sondern auch viel über das leben
der anderen kursteilnehmerinnen wie alt
was du als du zur schule gegangen ist
mit den vielen jahren hast du begonnen
während mittag und wie lange ich weiß
nicht vielleicht bis 14 machen das
kleine oder große klassen korte platten
290 schüler erzählen mir von seiner
schulzeit
das hat mir gefahrengut matte weniger
aber geschichte geografie und habe schon
viele jahre bis zur schule gegangen
sechs jahre lang hast du gerne länger
geblieben
solltest du heiraten
nein ich habe erst mit 23 geheiratet
ich habe gearbeitet
italienisch unterricht zwei stunden am
abend zweimal pro woche
vielen dank
das wort für heute ich denke dass dieser
kurs die frauen auch ein stück weit
ändern zitiert eine teilnehmerin hat mir
erzählt dass ich ihre rolle hier im
vergleich zu lena in ihrem heimatland
stark verändert hat hier bekommen wir
mehr achtung vor sich während des
unterricht können die frauen ihre kinder
betreuen lassen
auch matthias mann hat sechs monate lang
an einem sprachkurs teilgenommen
heute besucht er ihn nicht mehr faul
beginnt ein neuer lebensabschnitt nach
dem provisorium die erste eigene wohnung
in der schweiz in einem monat sollen
seine frauen kommen
[Musik]
die möbel hat er bei einem großen
schwedischen möbelhaus im internet
bestellt doch das zusammenbauen
überlässt er lieber den profis
[Musik]
es ist schon ein unterschied das haus
jetzt mit möbeln zu sehen und wenn dann
noch mega und dir hier sind wird es noch
schöner
ich kann es kaum erwarten nutzt die zeit
um sich über die abstimmung zum
atomausstieg zu informieren
firma ist im solar energie sektor tätig
die abstimmung interessiert ihn ein und
habe leider kenne ich die details dieser
abstimmung nicht
deshalb habe ich keine bestimmte meinung
dazu in indien werden solche fragen im
parlament entschieden
mir ist es eigentlich lieber wenn die
abgeordneten sich in themen einarbeiten
und dann für das volk die entscheidungen
fällen
dass es mir ehrlich gesagt lieber als
wenn ich selbst entscheiden dennoch
glaube ich dass direkte demokratie bei
bestimmten themen eine tolle sache sein
kann
besonders wenn die bevölkerung ein
gewisses bildungsniveau hat in der
schweiz funktioniert das schon sehr
lange hervorragend
ich bin wirklich gespannt wie diese
abstimmung am ende ausgeht
das wird mir einen einblick geben wie
die leute hier denken
[Applaus]
die möbel jetzt fast fertig raul regelt
noch ein paar details
jetzt wissen die rechnungen wo sie hin
müssen
[Musik]
das gute ist dass ich versichert was ich
etwas kaputt mache der schweiz ist das
so wichtig oder sagen wir mal das ist
ein guter grund sich bei den nachbarn
vorzustellen
[Musik]
ich gebe auf
lisa hat frei sie genieße es gemeinsam
mit ihrer freundin silvana zu kochen und
sich auszutauschen
irgendwann machte zwei das problem ist
dort schlafen
die beiden haben sich während eines
kurses kennen und schätzen gelernt
wir haben einige sachen hier genauso
machen und denken und aufgezogen sind in
derselben
das hat uns zusammengeführt vielleicht
haben wir weiter gesucht jemand mit dem
wir wieder so drehten sonntag sein
könnten wie wir sie gewinnen
ivana ist italienerin
[Musik]
im internet
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
beide haben in ihrem leben ähnliche
erfahrungen gemacht
das verbindet
[Musik]
es gibt wird die spiele ja die sind wohl
ziemlich gebunden sind glaube ich mehr
gefunden am land als
[Musik]
modelle mutation internationalität
wie wäre es mit dem marokkaner der winkt
ein marokkaner ein ausflug unter frauen
[Musik]
die angehende sozialarbeiter nicole ist
eine freundin der familie geworden
einer der wenigen schweizer kontakte auf
dem programm der themenparks miniatur
[Musik]
willkommen in der schweiz schaut mal
hier gibt es sogar den seen klein
wahnsinn um ein mädchen das bei ihren
großeltern lebt und ihnen mit den
schafen hilft und sie hat einen freund
der ihr eine menge beibringen so ein
gewisses häuschen auf spielerische art
vermittelt die schweizerin ihren
syrischen freundinnen die schweizer
kultur und wichtige fakten
es gibt mindestens zwölf kantone oder
weniger
20 24 23 20 56 honig war ganz nah dran
auch zwei jahre nach ihrer ankunft gibt
es für sie noch vieles zu entdecken in
der neuen heimat
davon mache ich ein foto das rote kreuz
krieg in der bier kommen erinnerungen an
die zerstörte heimat hoch was ich alles
so in den nachrichten sehe in lemgo
haben viele menschen nicht mal mehr
etwas zu essen
viele kinder sind krank die
geographielehrer möchte manchmal einen
test machen
ich habe ihm dann machen wir es lieber
nächste woche er sagt meistens ok und in
der woche drauf läuft genauso
[Musik]
doch der heute bin ich ein wenig früher
nach hause gekommen
juli kommt etwas später und wird recht
müde sein also bereite ich schon etwas
zu essen vor
allerdings werde ich das in zukunft wohl
nicht mehr so oft machen keinen wert
hoch sagte pitt normalerweise ist fabia
ein begeisterter koch heute jedoch tut
er sich ein wenig schwer
er wird ein heikles thema ansprechen
müssen
seine bereitschaftsdienste ich habe den
kalender mit meinen einsätzen für dieses
jahr bekommen müssen die wochenenden an
denen ich zu hause auf pikett sein muss
das heißt einsatzbereit rund um die uhr
ich teile mir das mit anderen schlössern
auf
[Musik]
juli wird nicht begeistert sein
fabio muss strategisch vorgehen sie
pendelt jeden tag drei stunden zwischen
wohnung und arbeit den beiden bleibt
wenig zeit füreinander
[Musik]
ich fühle mich gerade so wie ein schüler
der eine schlechte note geschrieben hat
und jetzt auf die schimpfe wartet
bewusst dass dieses papier unser
komplettes leben beeinflusst wir werden
nichts mehr frei entscheiden können
immerhin bringt uns dieses papier auch
geld ins haus
geburtstag können wir jedenfalls
vergessen gespürt rabatt dafür haben wir
ostern pfingsten wieder für schlecht aus
das ist echt übel weihnachten frei und
dafür müssen wir silvester in der gegend
bleiben nach lyon
das ist super das männlich planung
klar also ich schreibe in meiner agenda
und heute nachmittag
heute nachmittag haben wir etwas an
einem haus aus gemessen in einem dorf in
der nähe abruf so lerne ich den ganzen
kanton können anschließend haben wir
eine mutter geholfen die sich mit ihrem
baby ausgeschlossen hatte sie war echt
erleichtert
[Musik]
tobias neuer job wird zur
herausforderung für beide
kurz vor sieben morgens hier steht die
maschine bereits gelandet
[Musik]
ich möchte mich zu spät sein wenn sie
rauskommen
mit dem frisch gekauften auto geht zum
flughafen ankunft von mega und tirol ist
sich bewusst dass seine frau eine menge
aufgegeben hat um ihm ins neue leben in
der schweiz zu folgen wie ich mich damit
führen sie lässt ihren job und ihre
familie hinter sich
und das alles tut sie nur für mich ich
bin sehr glücklich dass die beiden mit
mir zusammen diesen schritt tun
wir haben alle nur ein leben das sollten
wir nutzen um die welt mit ihrem
menschen kennenzulernen
ich denke es ist eine bereicherung neue
dinge zu erfahren
das macht einen menschen komplett und
bereicherten
mit warmen kleidern für seine liebsten
schafft es raus auf die minute wie ein
echter schweizer
aber wie geht's
[Musik]
contra die waage flug das ist ja gar
nicht kalt zumindest
wir haben so viel dabei dass da auch
weil
höre ich die kälte aber es ist
auszuhalten von glos hat die anzahl der
gepäckstücke seiner frauen unterschätzt
in indien werde das problem schnell
gelöst wir würden dir einfach auf dem
floß nehmen
aber das geht nicht die wir nicht schon
am ersten tag ins gefängnis ist es mir
quer durch die innenstadt
schau mal das tempolimit
[Musik]
die vielen vögel mehrere tage abschied
nehmen sie ihn hinter mir meine
arbeitskollegen haben mir gesagt dass
ich hier nicht direkt wieder arbeiten
soll
aber die wissen wie wichtig ist für mich
ist einen job zu haben
[Musik]
raffiniert ist erneut unterwegs in
richtung schule diesmal allerdings für
einen ganz besonderen anlass zusammen
mit weiteren syrischen flüchtlingen
leute vor schülern aus ihrem leben
erzählen
bei diesem projekt einer schule in
stabio sollen vorurteile abgebaut und
flüchtlinge besser integriert werden
hallo ich bin ebrahim ich bin 20 jahre
alt commerce syrien und bin seit drei
jahren in der schweiz mit meiner mutter
und unsere nachbarin möchten wir euch
aus unserem leben erzählen
der krieg in syrien hat 2011 angefangen
2012 kam er nach aleppo ich gelebt habe
wenn man die bilder sieht denkt man das
ist wie in einem actionfilm aber in der
realität bedeutet das schlimme dinge wie
bomben
scharfschützen haben sie es nie bereut
von dort weg dann zu sein
sie sagt sie hat sich entschieden syrien
zu verlassen um für ihre kinder eine
sichere zukunft zu finden
sie hatte keine andere wahl als zu
flüchten
wenn der krieg in den nächsten jahren zu
ende wäre würden sie dann gerne wieder
zurück nach syrien
sie sagt ihre kinder haben jetzt
italienisch gelernt und sich an das
leben hier gewöhnt für sie selbst und
ihren mann wäre es kein problem aber für
die kinder nach dem einblick in ihr
leben bieten die syrer den schülern auch
noch eine kleine reise in die
kulinarische vielfalt ihrer heimat hier
ist stolz den jugendlichen etwas hat
ihrem land vermitteln zu können und
darauf zur verständigung beizutragen
viele menschen kommen ja hierher weil es
ihnen im krieg nicht erlaubt ist ein
richtiges leben zu führen
ich glaube man sollte eine person nicht
für das kritisieren sondern sie einfach
akzeptieren
am ende sind wir doch alle gleich es
gibt leute die lieben mich herrlich so
bin wie ich bin
andere mögen mich nicht weil ich so bin
wie ich bin
[Musik]
vielleicht sollten hier hinstellen oder
in die us zimmer da hat ja hier schon
einen auch die indischen traditionen
haben es bis in die schweiz geschafft
mit co-star kannst du bitte das erste
stein respekt habe ich gerade den
gottéron der bitte den göttern respekt
erweisen
jeder hat doch etwas an das wir glauben
dass es da oben jemanden gibt der auf
uns auf fast
also sagt uns mal die hausregeln regel
nummer eins zwei drittel vom schrank für
mich ein drittel für dich mach zu
blicken
das hier ist mein bereich außer für
deine schuhe
das hier ist dein teil nicht an erm das
reicht niemals das ist alles für dich
das hier ist auch für dich hier kannst
du alle deine warmen jacken reinhängen
fertig oder kommt noch mehr noch mehr
das hier ist für dir du kannst auch aus
rein tun das fenster geschlossen halten
und wenn du aus dem haus hieß immer alle
spuren runter hier geht das von hand
nein nicht wie ein l
das ist gerade sein das klingt jetzt
alles ein wenig hab's aber ich bin
sicher am ende macht das anziehen
[Musik]
toll wie er ganz alleine den haushalt
geschmissen hat ich bin wirklich
beeindruckt ich frage mich ob das ein
anderer mann auch so gut hinbekommen
hätte aber sag mal fühlst du dich nicht
einsam hier manchmal schon
besonders am wochenende
ich habe angst mich hier einsam zu
fühlen auch wenn ich einen job finde
keine ahnung
[Musik]
in der stadt el werden die neu
zugezogenen bewohner mit einem empfang
begrüßt
[Musik]
meine frau ist nach entzug sie wird
leicht verspätet sein zehn minuten
fabian trifft auf frisch zugezogene die
ab einwandern kennengelernt hat wenn
sich die ideen begegnen wenn wissen
ausgetauscht wird dann entsteht raum für
neues innovatives der irische dichter
william butler yeats hat gesagt
hier gibt es keine fremden nur freunde
die ich bisher noch nicht getroffen habe
in diesem sinne freue ich mich sie alle
heute hier in neuchatel als freunde
begrüßen zu dürfen
[Applaus]
nach den reden entdecken die neuzuzüger
produkte aus der region
mannheim
die während sascha teller wurst
bei uns ist doch die haut vom schwein
oder lecker mal schauen ob es auch käse
gibt
juli heimlich nach etwas ganz bestimmten
sucht nutzt verlieren die gunst der
stunde mit einem polizisten ein
wichtiges thema anzusprechen bevor wir
hierher kamen hat mir kein auto jetzt
haben wir 1 ich kenne mich mit dem
parksystem nicht aus eigentlich sollte
ich das nicht fragen aber was ist wenn
ich vergesse zu zahlen
dann gibt's eine busse ich frage deshalb
war es in manchen städten in frankreich
mehr sinn macht einfach nicht zu zahlen
und hin und wieder eine parkbusse in
kauf zu nehmen
das ist günstiger hier mischt juli hat
gefunden wonach sie gesucht hat den
bereich für werdende mütter
ich habe gehört man häufig einschreiben
soweit man weiß was man schwanger ist
aber dafür ist es jetzt schon zu spät
ich würde sagen es macht sinn sich
einzuschreiben sobald man weiß dass man
schwanger
damit man welcher später auch einen
krippenplatz zu haben
dollar
ja ich bin schwanger
[Musik]
informiere ich mich natürlich weil mir
alle gesagt hatten dass man sich so früh
wie möglich ein schreiben sollen
ich möchte sicher wissen ob ich das
gefährt machen muss oder ob ich noch
etwas zeit
ein neuer job nachwuchs in sicht
jetzt gilt es alles unter ein dach zu
bringen
[Musik]
lisa nutzt einen sonnigen tag für einen
spaziergang in den bergen oberhalb von
irland
[Musik]
meine schönen stiefel somit was soll ich
das jetzt vor zu
das bringt sogar glück und ich meine
glück kann man immer gebrauchen
seit fast zwei jahren ist leader jetzt
in der schweiz
vieles ist anders gekommen als sie es
sich gewünscht hat ich meine ich kann
jetzt nicht in meinem alter kann ich
schlecht kann ich mir nicht so gut
vorstellen dass ich dieses dazu gehören
das gefühl zum land irgendwie erleben
werde also kann ich mir eigentlich nicht
vorstellen
ich finde das schön also überhaupt
schweiz ein wunderschönes land höre ganz
genau wenn ich jetzt die schweiz
besuchen würde ich will mich in viele
verlieben in der schweiz
aber irgendwie ist das jetzt so dass
nicht aufgesucht bin und ich versuche
mich hier einzuleben
das leben geht weiter
meine vorstellung sind immer noch da
[Musik]
habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht umsetzen
können
wer dein board muss einfacher sein
sollte da aus meiner heimat ist und hier
habe ich sie auch noch nicht umsetzen
können
[Musik]
er hatte habe ich viele
stimmungsschwankungen auch
[Musik]
weil ich würde mich ja auch nicht wehtun
ist mein moment schwierig genug
[Musik]
besonders in einem fremden land
man sagt immer training ist das was
wofür es keine wörter gibt und manchmal
muss man weinen
das ist doch nicht schlimm
außer dass ich älter werde und meine
augen man schönheit kaputt macht
[Musik]
in der letzten folge von geriert sich
schweiz die einwanderer mega erfüllt
sich einen lebenstraum
zum ersten mal in ihrem leben stimmt sie
auf skiern einen schritt vorwärts 2
zurück doch das einleben in der schweiz
gestaltet sich schwierig hausfrau
vergeben
[Musik]
fabia versucht in seinem neuen metier
fuß zu fassen
ihre schlüssel duplizieren das kriegen
wir hin
fabian jolie haben noch einige hürden zu
nehmen
das hier ist der geburtstag mit
badewanne kann man die ganze zeit dabei
sein
[Musik]
familie al sheikh möchte sich mehr
integrieren doch unter ihren freunden
sind mehr flüchtlinge als schweizer wir
warten afrika sie hat heute geburtstag
und sie hat uns viel geholfen
hier angekommen die ankunft von dieser
sohn soll sie über enttäuschung und
heimweh hinwegtrösten
da gibt es currywurst
[Musik]
mehr